2020 une année à oublier pour l'économie
avec le colis de 19 la france a connu
une récession historique à laquelle
l'état a répondu par le quoi qu'il en
coûte
de quoi limiter la casse pour l'instant
mais ces milliards d'argent public sont
ils une réponse pérenne à l'aggravation
du chômage
après tout notre économie était
peut-être déjà malade avant la pandémie
on va en parler tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir à bonsoir à
jacques merci d'être avec nous au soir
se vanta et quelle année donc 2020 pour
l'économie est ce qu'on peut comment
fait en tirer le bilan réellement oui on
peut tout à fait et c'est effectivement
une année extrêmement difficile
l'économie française comme d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des autres économies mais
peut-être plus particulièrement
l'économie française a été frappé de
plein fouet par la crise sanitaire
alors bien sûr le choc de cette crise a
été en partie atténuée par l'action de
l'état et vous avez tout à fait raison
de citer le quoi qu'il en coûte prononcé
par emmanuel macron dans son discours du
mois de mars
néanmoins il est très clair aussi que
certains secteurs ont été plus
particulièrement touchées et mettront
vraisemblablement des années à se
relever justement cette crise sanitaire
at elle été un choc aussi majeur qu'on
le prétend jacques oui absolument
absolument samantha on a connu pendant
l'année et 2020 un recul du pib donc du
produit intérieur brut entre -11 et -12%
c'est sans précédent même pendant la
crise de 1929
on n'avait pas eu un tel chiffre sur une
telle année maintenant ce qu'il faut
dire aussi et c'est un point important
et on va le voir justement sur ce
graphique c'est que en réalité la
croissance française et la consommation
avait arrêté de croître dès le troisième
voire le quatrième trimestre de l'année
donc ce qui est extrêmement frappant
aussi c'est le fait que cette crise
sanitaire elle n'est venue frapper une
économie qui n'allait pas bien qui était
déjà malade
alors est-ce que la france finalement
elle sentir plus mal qu'eux
ses voisins on peut le penser on peut le
penser effectivement samantha si on
regarde les chiffres comparatifs
on va voir que la france comme l'italie
sont des pays qui ont été plus
particulièrement frappé par cette crise
alors on sait que l'italie avait mais
des problèmes économiques extrêmement
important avant mais on voit que la
france et l'italie sont parmi les pays
qui ont le plus plongé inversement
l'allemagne s'en tire moins mal on ne
voit que nous sommes sous la moyenne de
la zone euro et l'ours qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir que les états
unis dont pourtant la gestion de la
crise sanitaire sont très très loin
d'être exemplaire on avait beaucoup de
critiques anodin le trump là dessus et
bien les états unis en fait s'en tire
nettement mieux que nous dans ces
conditions jacques or on imagine le
chômage il aurait dû exploser
oui effectivement effectivement et ce
qui a permis de d'éviter que le chômage
explose pour l'instant c'est bien
entendu les mesures de chômage partiel
ceci étant il faut voir si on regarde
les données de pôle emploi que
l'ensemble des catégories qui représente
le chômage réel ce qu'on appelle dans le
langage de pôle emploi ou de la dares
les catégories à b et d et bien en voix
yann très nette pic au moment du premier
confinement par contre les catégories c
e qui représente les quasi chômeurs
diminue pourquoi parce que ils ont été
absorbés dans les catégories à b et d et
l'ours qui est très intéressant c'est de
voir que évidemment dans la période qui
va suivre le premier confinement il y à
une baisse
du nombre des véritables chômeurs mais
cette baisse ne fasse pas le pic du mois
d'avril
on voit que l'on va rester visiblement à
un niveau élevé et cela s'est bien
entendu sans les résultats du 2ème
confinement et sans évidemment l'effet
de l'arrêt du système de chômage partiel
qui se produira très probablement dans
les prochaines on parle du chômage ac
cela nous amène aux jeunes directement
menacés les jeunes qui ont payé un lourd
tribut à la crise
oui c'est absolument évident les jeunes
aussi on appelle jeunes 10 ans les
demandeurs d'emploi entre 18 et 30 ans
c'est vraiment la catégorie qui a été le
plus touché on le voit alors c'est la
catégorie qui est le plus touché par le
choc du confinement au mois d'avril
c'est aussi la catégorie qui est
peut-être le plus aidé le plus sensible
justement aux mesures de chômage partiel
néanmoins avec non pas la fin mais
disons la restriction du chômage partiel
après le premier confinement et bien on
voit que la courbe des demandeurs
d'emploi de 18 à 30 ans remontez remonte
de manière nettement plus significative
que par exemple pour les 30 60 ans pour
les 30-50 ans pour les 51 65 ans donc
les mesures prises par l'état ont permis
d'éviter le pire
ça il faut le dire le système du chômage
partiel a joué le rôle je dirais d'un
amortisseur extrêmement puissant ceci
étant ce qu'a fait la france n'est pas
en réalité différent de ce qu'on fait de
nombreux autres pays européens
il suffit de regarder par exemple sur
les sources du fonds monétaire
international
on voit que
l'aide aux emplois c'est le soutien aux
emplois et il a même été plus important
en proportion évidemment en italie qu'il
ne l'a été en france alors ce qui est
très intéressant c'est de voir que en
france avec la fin du premier
confinement il retombe très vite alors
que dans de nombreux autres pays comme
par exemple l'italie l'allemagne voire
la belgique
eh bien il va se maintenir dans la
période d'après le premier confinement
alors c est jack
elle ne concerne pas tous les emplois
oui tout à fait et ça à samantha il fait
bien le préciser il ya la fois les aides
qui concerne évidemment les salariés ce
sont eux qui sont éligibles au chômage
partiel
et puis il ya les aides qui vont être
plutôt sur les travailleurs indépendants
et les auto entrepreneurs
alors là ce qui est intéressant c'est
que on a mixé si vous voulez les deux
données qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit là
encore que l'italie fait à peu près la
même chose que nous nous ne sommes
réellement différent que par les aides
qui ont été attribuées aux salariés ou
donc aux employés pour ce qui est des
indépendants des pays que l'italie
l'allemagne
mais même par exemple l'espagne ont fait
nettement mieux que nous alors tout ça
évidemment à un coup oui oui bien sûr
bien sûr samantha c'est justement la
question du quoi qu'il en coûte bien sûr
cela aura un coût
et on sait déjà que normalement la dette
publique française qui étaient autour de
99 % à la fin de l'année dernière eh
bien elle va se situer à la fin 2020
entre 116 et 120 % donc oui ça a un coût
mais là encore il faut le souligner la
france n'a pas été le pays qui a le plus
aidé son économie à trois pays qui ont
aidé plus l'économie que nous et c'est
là encore c'est extrêmement intéressant
de voir l'italie qui a un système qui
est pas si différent du nôtre
l'allemagne et le royaume uni
le royaume uni que l'on présenterait
souvent comme un modèle de société
libérale et bien non il a fait plus d
aides que la france en conclusion est ce
qu'on peut véritablement parler d'une
année noire
certainement et cette année je pense que
nous serons de très nombreux à vouloir
l'oublier a pour de très nombreuses
raisons les restrictions à la liberté
dans la vie quotidienne mais aussi pour
les questions économiques
maintenant il faut savoir que dans cette
année noire à bien certains secteurs ont
été beaucoup plus touchés que d'autres
il ya évidemment le secteur de
l'aéronautique pas seulement le secteur
des transports aériens mais aussi le
secteur de la construction aéronautique
airbus est un très gros employeurs en
france après tout nous sommes le réel
père d'airbus il faut toujours le
rappeler
jusqu'au secteur du tourisme le secteur
du que du petit commerce a aussi été
très largement touchés je ne parle même
pas du secteur de la culture qui est
complètement sinistré oui effectivement
c'est une année qui a été extrêmement
difficile et
la question de savoir comment nous
relèverons non pas en 2021 mais plutôt
en 2022 en 2023 elle est aujourd'hui
posée c'est vrai vous avez raison à
jacques j'aimerais pouvoir dire que
c'est une année vite à oublier n'est pas
sûr effectivement comme vous le dites
que 2020 soit une sinécure et vient bien
sûr vous reviendrez nous ont parlé
l'année prochaine à bientôt jacques
merci